what is the comic premise the comic
premise is the gap between real reality
and comic reality it's a rule change
that takes normal reality and turns it
into something else
uh you here's a good example in the
situation comedy Married with Children
which I'm sure you know
if you don't know it's about horrible
people who somehow manage to live
together the comic premise is these
people who have no business spending
five minutes in each other's company
somehow managed to hold it together real
reality is not like that if these people
were real people in the real world they
would run screaming from one another the
comic reality says to the audience if
you will accept the premise that these
horrible people can live together we're
going to give you some fun so the comic
premise is the change of reality the
altered reality that the comedian offers
in order to welcome the audience into
his or her or their world
on the level of stand-up as an example
you can find a comic premise in
something like just when you thought
Airlines couldn't get any worse
the audience understands you're not
going to tell me what really happens
with Airlines you're going to tell me an
exaggerated version of it an alternate
reality version of it a Comic version of
it so the comic premise is
airlines are even worse than you think
on that level it's easy to understand
that we're not going to be talking about
error error travel in a straight sense
we're going to talk about it in an
exaggerated or bent sense so the comic
premise is the thing you do to bend
reality
what are the components of a common
premise
the main component of a comic premise is
rule change
in this world
let's take another example from from a
well-known sitcom we can think about
Kramer from Seinfeld his comic premise
his comic perspective or filter is
there's nothing I can't do like I'm
Kramer everybody knows he's Kramer and
because we know he has that attitude
about himself we will allow him to do
any bizarre thing he wants to do and the
more bizarre the better it all stems
from a single rule change
in the real world this loser doofus does
not prosper
they don't they just don't they're
losers their doofuses nobody gives them
the time of day in the world of in the
comic world of the story of Seinfeld
This loser doofus triumphs every time so
the rule change is losers win
uh now let's take that as an example
let's say we we like the rule change
losers win but we want to make something
new out of it
we could say something like the world's
poorest family wins the lottery
in the real world that's not happening
for all intents and purposes as a friend
of mine once said he did the
mathematical modeling for the California
Lottery and he said to five significant
figures your chances of winning are the
same whether you play or not
so
so we know in real reality it's not
going to happen but we allow the comic
premise to change the situation normal
poor family all of a sudden they're
endowed with great riches doesn't matter
how we're going to watch poor people be
rich and it's going to be fun that's
what a comic premise does it takes
normal reality and turns it upside down
what's the difference between a great
comic premise and a bad comic premise
this almost feels like an SAT question
as it has actually what I'm reflecting
on now is I do a lot of work coaching
people for interviews and one of the
things that I talk about is when you get
a hard question you're going to want to
blab you're going to want to say stuff
that doesn't matter so
um well let's see and instead it's good
just to have a moment of silence
or talk about something completely
irrelevant install while you're trying
to figure out what you really want to
say which is exactly what I'm doing now
because I don't really know what is the
difference between a good premise and a
bad premise except
as we said before a good premise a good
idea will stand the weight of
development and stand the test of time
that is to say if it's interesting to me
now and it's interesting next week and
next year or funny now funny next week
and next year then that's a good premise
if it's funny now and
upon further Express further
investigation it stops being funny it's
not such a good premise I have an
example
I was working on a joke about
virtually meaningless superpowers like
if you could have any superpower what
would you choose
would you choose something dumb and and
I said I would choose the superpower of
the ability to carry groceries on a
bicycle
and somebody said well that's just
balance
I realized okay that's not a very good
superpower not a good premise but there
is something funny in the poor guy who
had the chance to pick his one
superpower and he wasted it on balance
because he thought it was something
better than that and that's a good
premise because that's something I can
work with I can think about somebody who
makes a big mistake and suffers the
consequences
rather than thinking about the mistake
itself
you're asking me a question and as I'm
answering it I'm kind of unpacking it
a good premise is about something
sustainable a bad premise is not about
something sustainable
okay so you talked about earlier uh job
interviews so if we I don't know did you
see Emily the criminal you see the
openings yes okay so she's in this job
interview and and it really sort of
establishes who she is in that moment
and then they they kind of uh show that
they have this like file they've done
their research on her and um you talked
about how I'm not even sure where I'm
going yeah now now I'm kind of stumped
wearing it together okay there you go
and I'm willing to to be okay with that
but it was a great scene in that you
learn who she is in that moment
what you're speaking of is something
called a character key and this is
something else that I teach and talk
about all the time when you're creating
characters your first job is to
introduce them to the audience in a way
that the audience will understand you
want to tell them two important things
in a comedy those two important things
are
how they will behave in all situations
and how they will be funny in all
situations and a good character key will
do all of that
so when we think about that opening
moment we're getting everything we need
to know in order to predict the stories
that will take place in this world and
also the character perspective that will
give us value on a comic level
where writers go wrong is thinking they
don't need that or they should delay it
they try to introduce the characters
without introducing them let's just
imagine a scene that starts I walk into
the room and I say hello to you and you
say hello back and I say how is your day
and you say not so bad and I say that's
good and then I go to the refrigerator
for something to eat I have spent a lot
of time not defining myself
but if I
walk in and try to open the refrigerator
door on the wrong side and say who
changed the sides of the refrigerator
door or something funny I'm telling you
I don't know what's going on and I think
I know what's going on and that's going
to drive me into mistake after mistake
and story after Story
or or I I see you I say hey how was your
day and you launch into you know what's
wrong with the world and you have a
whole Manifesto everything that's wrong
and you're up on your soapbox and I was
just about to check my email and I just
wanted to be polite you you did you did
so many great things there let's
deconstruct it you boil the character
key down to two lines how was your day
let me tell you what's wrong with the
world that's so genius because how was
your day creates an expectation and the
expectation is we're going to hear fine
we're going to hear polite stuff when I
tell you let me tell you what's wrong
with the world I'm defeating expectation
well you as the Creator are defeating
the audience's expectation immediately
you're engaged then the words let me
tell you what's wrong with the world
Perfect characters key perfect predictor
of what will happen next this is a guy
who's going to complain about everything
and be wrong and be in conflict with the
world and be just hilariously
misguided for 150 episodes let's go